protesters chant in support of the man
they say is the rightful president of
Cameroon Maurice canto they gathered
outside a military court in the capital
yaoundé where the main opposition leader
is one of dozens of politicians standing
trial they're accused of insurrection
and rebellion against the government
charges that carry the death penalty I
have travelled more than 600 kilometers
to attend this historical trial we asked
the government to release political
prisoners calm tensions this year the
judgement will unfortunately be done in
the absence of the concern we're used to
the presence of police this is what
comes with a dictator this is what
tyranny is a civilian is tried in a
military tribunal will continue
protesting until there is change Kanto
lost to President Paul Biya who's ruled
for 35 years in last year's elections
but camcos party the Cameroon
Renaissance movement accuses the
government of rigging the votes results
[Applause]
following anti-government protests come
to and more than 80 other politicians
were arrested in January their defense
teams accuse the authorities of denying
them basic human and legal rights in
court the lawyers all of them are no
sittings
the Rakata standing because of knows G
has nosepiece the accused persons are
not in a good condition to be able to
defend themselves human rights groups
are calling for the immediate release of
Camco and say it's part of a violent
crackdown by the president against any
form of dissent this is also occurring
amidst a series of other issues
happening in Cameroon most pressing of
which is the crisis that continues to
unfold in the Anglophone regions and
we've also seen the courts used against
separatist leaders in these regions as
well the trial has been adjourned to
next month after one of the accused a
former adviser to president bia
collapsed in court certified earth and
jazeera